[Music]
yeah yeah what up what up
Blagh Blagh here the pier Wow team some
meetings in Boston which is an
interesting feeling because I love
Boston humans but I hate the Patriots so
much that even when I'm here I feel like
I'm in a more of a warrior mindset like
I'm ready to fight verbally and
physically at all times with anybody
so anyway Batman did a good job because
all the meetings we're doing today are
things that we cannot film and so I'll
probably give him a good rant at the
airport but to fill out the vlog I guess
you did something and got some questions
so we're gonna do some Q&A here which i
think is a good format for us in general
because Q&A is like my like askgaryvee
is like far and few between like I think
once even a week if we look at my
schedule just doing Q&A is a good format
so anyway vlog I hope you like this
format
go ahead Bobby Bevan so how do you
balance your not the person's need ice
your bad guy sit yourself up but you
know how fun it would be for that person
to have their name of you okay fair
enough good how do you balance clouds
so to find everybody how I defined
clouds and dirt clouds to me is like the
why the strategy the macro the big
thinking the big picture the operating
system of like how you do things and
then the dirt is having the humility to
go to these meetings to actually I post
all my Instagram photos the doing the
humility ego humility strategy execution
clouds and dirt the way a balanced it is
they're both important at all times I
can swing back and forth to them I can
literally go from a meeting where like
the call I had on the way out to our
first meeting here today in Peru I was
with vaynermedia's c-suite about a
restructuring of how we handle all our
business super meta and then literally
hung up and I posted something on
Instagram and wrote all the copy as we
were walking into our last meeting to me
I balanced them by doing whichever one
is needed at the time and so I don't
think about it as balancing it I think
about it as time allocation like what
should I be doing with my time and I
think that you know you made a joke of
like we did a shoot for a client that we
debated on the phone for 10 minutes
where them should be located for that I
think that's being in the middle right
I think pandering to the way companies
do things we just had a meeting where
they're like oh that was provocative us
as as the gallery media group holds and
all the other things we do us doing what
every other publishing does company does
is not a good idea that's the middle
that's not gonna get you to the next
place and so for me I'm just in the
mindset of you know do either doing
humble dirty work like the reason I am
the best strategist in social media out
there I really believe this is because I
do both I both sit at the top of a media
company that really doesn't at scale for
the biggest comers a little bit at the
same token there's very few humans that
put out a hundred [ __ ] 40 pieces of
content by hand a week and reads the
cognate I literally just replied to Kyle
in my client comments whoo and I'm gonna
show you because I don't think you guys
believe me when I do these [ __ ] rants
I literally just replied to Kyle
one second before babbles like let's do
this video like literally
what I was doing one second before then
was replying to like literally like
literally hearted Kyle's comment of I'm
digging the recent pics in quotes man
right like many many people watching
here would argue that my time at this
point of my career of reading Kyle's
comment and Harding it in that minute
was a bad use of my time
I think the dirt is the reason why I
come up with such good clouds being in
the trenches drives my strategy I live
in reality and practicality not in
thesis or ideology or reading headlines
or reading about people doing marketing
so I don't I don't balance it I just do
whatever is needed at that second macro
you know it's back to macro micro micro
speed I'm just always doing something
right Bobby like that is the big
breakthrough everybody on the team says
like there's just every second and so
the reason I can do something every
second is and I don't watch a YouTube
video or stand by the wall water cooler
and talk about the Rockets game for 10
minutes is because I always value the
dirt and so in that half a second that I
had right now in the transition of the
call that I just had about a macro
Vayner X strategy right the second
transition I had before I started doing
a macro thing like the vlog was Harding
[ __ ] Kyle's two cents on my last
Instagram post clouds and dirt
whatever you want to do on that
what uh what do you do to recharge
yourself in a physically exhausted sleep
physically sleep
sleeeeep matters not always rolling but
you can ask something we won't put it in
the blog if it's sensitive information
I think Ryan just wants more vlog time
but on our faces yep yep cool have Lisa
there just to scoop up yep
question jo-jo
how in your 20s were you able to blow
off parties and girls these are stuff
and just folks oh I could answer this
one
nobody invited associate with him
did you see have you seen a picture of
his license that one Ryan Hart with 27
Instagram right now I think it's a cute
photo I think it's cute
you know that's fair Ryan was much
cooler than me you know as you know as
this you know as a Long Island Club
promoter he no question had more of that
more of that opportunity I think it
comes down to for me it was easy because
I was obsessed I was obsessed with my
career and I continue to be I you know I
think the reason I can play in the dirt
is my obsession and so I just think it's
priorities you know most people are just
going to be average human beings and
want to live through you know party life
and in their 20s and be a Goldman Sachs
banker and play tennis you know that's
most people the average the people that
are not remembered and then some and
some people and some people are going
for all time and I was going for all
time and I was willing to give up the
thing that most people want and during
that time I just I was I had a burr I
forget you know recently I've remembered
I had a burning desire to pay back my
parents for being the best parents I
really wanted to build my family
business for my parents a lot more than
I've recalled until we you know as I'm
like going through all these motions I
was passionate like just obsessed with
building my family business for them
because they had put me on so much
emotionally not you know people always
say you know when people like to razz me
they're like easy for you to say you
were given a liquor store I wasn't
I built a business for my family and
left with no economics because
emotionally my parents perfectly
parented me which has now been the
foundation of all my success
last one
Khris Khris if you decide to go all in
and you get burned by business partner
you cut all ties or just accept how you
were played
well I think the way that question was
asked it sounds like there was a prior
relationship with that person so if that
person is a friend you know like you
know these are very personal questions
here's what I would say I am utterly
unemotional when it comes to business
because that's just you know the game of
businesses business is real like you can
handle it any way you want my default is
always to be the bigger person because I
think that's the ultimate leverage and
so you know even with the peanut people
I compete with which I compete with
feverishly even people that have I mean
look there's people there was a there
was a gentleman who stole hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of wine from
Wine Library went to jail like hundreds
of thousands and I've forgiven him and
you know interacted with him through the
years I just I think grudges are poison
and our anchors that hold you down so
for me I think it's about chalking it up
to experience I think if you truly were
played if it's not your perceived notion
that you were played if every one of us
saw the situations that oh yeah you were
played you know I Chuck it up to you
were played be the bigger person
you know and I would actually have I
would have I would also feel sad you
know to me anybody who does something
dishonest is coming from a place of
weakness I kind of feel bad for the
person that played me so you know
yeah I mean I I I just I think the
higher road is strategically right you
go faster
you're not looking backwards when you're
looking backwards people are passing you
by and so yeah I'd feel bad for them
cool yeah that cue a fire I think we
just hacked a new system leaving the
comments if you like this new vlog
askgaryvee concept I think it's gonna
[ __ ] work but like I say always